I always show up and show out whenever I
show up anywhere if we understand how to
deal and manage and and and monitor our
emotions so much of what we do will
become better that's how you make those
great changes because young people are
so powerful it's a tough industry you
know you're here today gone tomorrow if
you don't have other things in the
pipeline you'll be stuck you tell the
truth
good there she is
Hey oh yeah I love that energy first
thing in the morning how are you yes
indeed morning is my time I love it
so this is a judge Lin if you don't know
judge Lin she's the host of the divorce
court she's also really passionate about
preventing domestic violence she has an
organization called bloom 365 org and
just came out with her is it your first
book
my third her third book it's on Amazon
came out in October letters to her
daughter that she would share she's got
six sons and wanted to send letters to
the daughter that she thought she never
had right
judge Lin welcome aboard oh thank you so
much it's so lovely to meet you even if
it's across the border which you
couldn't cross yeah sorry about that
that was some fun times Border Patrol
2020 is an interesting place to be I
imagine there's so many things that I
could dive into on your story so I'm
trying to pick kind of where to start
what what do you think is the the
through line between what you do so
you've got you've got divorce court your
your your what I love about it is you're
also giving advice you're actually
trying to save families you're trying to
help people through the show but you've
also got Bloom you've also got the book
what's the through line for you for all
the work that you do the through line
for me I think is one that is really
unrecognized by myself because I've
always called myself an accidental
overachiever that's never accomplished
anything she set out to do I was
supposed to be a doctor that's what I
always wanted to be and through a series
of lateral steps I just ended up here I
never intended to be a
judge I never intended to be on
television but my through line is I
always show up and show out whenever I
show up anywhere and then once I do that
I see what touches my heart and I play
that note for people who are watching
your show or buying the book or trying
to get involved in the organization what
do you want them to feel or what's the
message that you have if they're hanging
around with gentlemen what what I want
them to feel is the best question I
think I've ever been asked because it's
all about feeling what you know doesn't
matter if you don't feel it in a way
that allows you to do something about it
anger upset fear frustration we tend to
be running on buckets of it of late my
very first book was about my mother who
was an incredible emotional manager and
if you get nothing else from me I want
you to be able to understand recognize
and control your own emotional life if
we were all able to do that in a more
effective manner we would all be able to
deal with each other in a more effective
less costly less dangerous left lethal
manner so you know behind me this is a
picture of me when I'm eight or nine
years old and that's a mom as well
standing over so we both love our moms I
what what are some of the lessons you
think people need to like what are from
your mom what are two or three the
biggest lessons that people need to
understand one of them is you have to be
able to understand how other people feel
everybody is always so centered on this
is what I need and this is what I want I
would be more able to get something I
want from you if I understand how you
feel because if I understand how you
feel I can give you what you need while
figuring out a way to get what I want a
lot of people want to talk and talk and
talk and talk and talk and they don't
want to listen I would also ask people
to be aware of your emotional life
sometimes like your boss will make you
ain't make you angry you angry on the
way home and then you will you yell at
your life you got to know where the man
is suppose
to go we have a lot of displaced anger
these days and from blue365 what we do
is we go into high schools and middle
schools and teach young people how to
have healthy relationships so it stops
bullying it's it doesn't stop it helps
prevent bullying helps prevent domestic
violence and I'll tell you in one school
we were doing our program we stayed
there for a week and we require them to
write what's called elephant and womb
cards we don't care you can write screw
you to the moon and back on it but you
have to write something on it and send
it back and one guy wrote I'm gonna kill
that guy and every guy everybody who
didn't believe that guy did what he did
to me
we found that young man and we got him
plugged in to help people young people
are screaming out there from being
bullied from from from feeling less than
and now that the mass shooting thing is
in the in the air and the gestalt that's
in our society that's what people who
feel powerless default to if we
understand how to deal and manage and
and and monitor our emotions so much of
what we do will become better and is
your passion really diving down into the
youth yes because that's where the
greatest gains can be made we've we
raised a generation that does not
believe we raise a generation that does
know one healthy relationship domestic
violence is is a is an epidemic we don't
see it until it becomes lightning and
crazing when someone actually dies but
it is an epidemic and even politically
we have become emotional and childlike
you can disagree with me but I don't
have to call you a name I don't have to
cancel you I don't have to wish you to
die and to the extent that we have
allowed our emotions to carry away with
us we have created a society more
difficult to monitor if we get to the
children you know smoking 1960s they
were teaching in the school you can't
smoke and I made my daddy stop who was
smoking since 1940 that's where
the greatest games can happen it's funny
my dad my dad was a smoker too when it's
my older sister that made him stop pal
mouths with no filter I mean boyfriend
was going for it but it was that's
that's how you make those great changes
cuz young people are so powerful and why
domestic violence as the thing that
you're sticking your flag in the ground
pork when I was a municipal court judge
I saw about four hundred domestic
violence cases every year and I saw it
in good whole in socially economically
well-off homes and homeless where there
were struggle in religious homes and
non-religious homes it was a constant
theme of power and control and women yet
were just screaming about with their
lack of sense of value and I thought if
one-fourth of our homes are built on
this pressure and distress what are we
doing to our kids and I just thought it
was just so prevalent and somebody had
to care so I decided to do that I love
it now a lot of the people who watch on
my channel they're entrepreneurs
entrepreneurs struggle a lot with
managing their emotions with keeping
relationships what advice would you give
to them my advice would go back to
understand whom you're talking to
understand who you're dealing with
because you know what your goal is you
know what you want and we very
registered but if I want to sell you
something if I know what your needs are
if I know how you feel if I know what
you're afraid of I've know what you want
I'm better able to do so so don't be so
full you know how you feel you know what
you want then you got to go into
straight business mode and not get
emotionally derailed by what may occur
what's here so what's your strategy for
how to deal with anger and emotions
whether you're whether you're going in
and teaching kids they're dealing with
somebody who's older if that's one of
the most important lessons from your mom
we actually manage our emotions better
we do by taking it on as a field of
study in and of itself we learn math and
learn arithmetic we don't we don't say I
need to know how to manage emotions I
have a plan for every first you have to
know how you feel you have to understand
when anger comes on you you have to
understand what is my nature I am NOT
personally I am naturally fearful I am
naturally introverted I am naturally a
loner and not gregarious now clearly I
have things because of what I do but if
I didn't know they were there I wouldn't
be able to deal with it so you got to
know where you are you got to know where
your head is where your emotions are and
then you have to pick one I picked my
fear of traveling and I worked it like a
job I would do when I first started
divorce court I was living in Cleveland
in order to get on that plane I had to
have two valium and two Jack Daniels and
I would just wobble on the flight pass
out and I realized I could become a
drunk you know
so one valium went next valium went one
Jack went second Jack went it was a job
and and I worked that like instead of
saying I'm afraid to fly this is what I
have to do to do it I said I'm afraid to
fly I have to do something about that
and what was what do you think the
biggest challenge was for you because
people look at your show people hear you
speak not many people would think that's
a fearful woman who's introverted and
NACA various and right so to become to
build the woman that you are now you
built her yes what what was the biggest
challenge you had to overcome to change
your identity and build this new woman
the biggest chance I had to come I had
to campaign to become judge you know
like a politician and for a person who
doesn't like to meet new people I belong
to no organizations no Club I got like
one friend I had to go door to
or and introduce myself to people I
didn't know and who didn't want to be
bothered with me right every day so I
made it a game I do X number of doors I
get X number of Oreo cookies cuz I love
Oreo cookies okay you know or I would
play another game on another day I'm
gonna predict the response that I get at
the door and then there was another
reward at the end of the day for that it
all became again him after a while by
the time the election was there I could
go up to a door and it didn't bother me
because my brain was engaged in other
things other than worrying about what
Joe Blow was gonna say to me and what
was the why that made you push through
to even go off and do that like why care
so much yeah why care about like why
even try to go and become a lot of
people who are in your situation would
say well I could never be a judge I'm
not gonna go campaigning I'm not gonna
door to door I'm introverted I don't
want to meet people you know I have
anxiety going up and knocking on doors
like what drove you to say I have to go
off and do this it's not gonna be an
answer you're like I married a man with
four kids I had a number one I was at a
large law firm the first black woman
they ever had and ten years and they
looked at me and said we like what you
do at trial but you're not bringing any
clients in so we don't think you're
gonna make it here I was 33 Wow and it
had a brand new baked not brand new he
was like eight months old and the guy
down the hall was into politics and he
liked me and he liked the idea of having
more color in the judiciary cuz it was
pretty much white mm-hmm and he said I
think he would be a great judge I want
you to go and try to get this
appointment that's open I didn't get the
appointment but when the judge the
municipal judge in my area retired he
said you should run and I said okay Matt
because I thought you know I wasn't
going anywhere here so let me do
something else I was tired
judges set their own docket the court
so six blocks from my house a lot of it
was personal that's why nobody likes to
yes no I listen I think of all the
things that I love and respect the most
about you is you tell the truth yeah I
talk too much not to that that would in
in watching over you know your videos
and in speaking to you you'll have these
moments where like you just you get into
a rhythm and you're saying things in
threes and it just starts to flow
through you and and it's really wild and
amazing to watch was was that just does
that just naturally come out did you do
training are you thinking about it like
how does how does that when you're
summoning you know judge Lin to come out
there and and do her thing how did how
was that created that was natural okay
that was a natural ability when I got on
the bench I won the I won by my judicial
my judge she seat by one vote on
election night six votes while overall
and when I ran for re-election I won by
eighty percent of the vote and I have a
natural facility to speak I think
there's a lot of reasons why I might but
I've always had a natural facility to
speak and as long as I continue to read
daily because that just lets words and
melodies and rhythms and syntax lay in
your head and I've become passionate
about something I can pull on that
without thinking and when I get in a
rhythm I go that is one thing that is
natural to me talking about role models
role models growing up role models
through your career even may be role
models now who influences you who makes
you be a better woman it's my mother and
my father I mean they drew the most
extraordinary people I've ever met my
mother was an emotional genius I wrote a
whole book about her she was able to
handle my father was bipolar he was born
in 1919 a black man in five foot two
inches tall in West Virginia he used to
work two weeks in the coal mines and go
two weeks to college two weeks in the
coal mines has he responds
for feeding his family since he was 13
that man died with a trust fund that he
paid for my Harvard education University
of Pennsylvania Dartmouth for my sister
medical or school for my sister out of
his back pocket now a black man from
1919 managing that I mean my god he was
never late
he was like with you go you go you know
there was no you know you couldn't put
your half your ass and you got to put
your whole ass in that's how daddy was
and mother was very good at managing him
he was bipolar so she was a very good
emotional manager and those were they
were an unlikely pair that made an
extraordinary couple that they were both
born in abject poverty I'm a judge on TV
and my sister who has a real job is a
neurologist bang great parents
it's the next book about your dad I
wanted to be I really do but I know so
little about him because he was very
very unwilling to speak of himself and
all of his family's gone so it should be
though cuz I'm crazy buddy I am me I
could tell it's a minute.what so so you
know lessons from afar than from your
father what would you say when there are
a lot of things that you can't control
take all the control you can about the
things that you can control he couldn't
make a white law firm take him but he
was always the most prepared when he
came to court he couldn't you know he
was never late he used to the first
advice he always gave me as a lawyer was
never let him catch you one attack you
know go those deep you know don't let
him take you out the 30 days and all
that kind of stuff be on top of that I
mean he was driven all day every day he
took one vacation in the 36 years that I
knew him he worked on Friday I remember
he took me one Christmas he took me into
his office and make me call people on
Christmas Day for business and I would
call I said I'm so sorry mister man I
didn't mean to go he said listen honey I
know your father he's always trying to
make
what does he want it's just you know he
didn't believe in the words no he just
didn't believe in it
hmm and was your inspiration to become a
lawyer because of him no he wanted me to
be a physician he was mad when I became
a lawyer okay he was like you know he
wanted most being my sister's to become
doctors my sister became a doctor I
fooled around too much in college to do
all of that and I said daddy I don't
know what to do and he said well you
better find something to do because I'm
gonna stop paying your bills if you
don't go to graduate school I said okay
I'll go to law school I mean it was it
was not I don't have that set a goal
long term thing I kind of set a goal and
then I watched my periphery to see what
would be best that I hadn't thought
about yet because my job on TV was the
periphery it was not at all the goal
right and what's I mean it's been
awesome watching your entire kind of
career blossom or bloom to your would
what's on the periphery now lots of
other things I have an episodic going on
that I wrote a script that I am pitching
I got a a podcast that's about to start
I've started on my next book and that's
about
oh and I'm on marriage boot camp for Wii
TV pitching a show with some people that
you would know but I don't want to say
their names so someone asked me how many
jobs do you need and I said all that I
can get okay
it's a tough industry you know you're
here today gone tomorrow if you don't
have other things in the pipeline you'll
be stuck and how are you transitioning
your message so I mean you're doing
you're doing a lot of Instagram you're
posting your content you've got the
shows on YouTube I see that's what
you're you know linking up in your
accounts - how are you transitioning the
message from mainstream TV to social
media and reaching down into the younger
generation I don't think I'm doing a
very good job of it tell you the truth I
am trying I have a son that's 27 that is
interested in this kind of
and he's kind of actually have two sons
that are trying to help me with my my
Instagram and YouTube because it doesn't
come naturally to me and you know I'm 60
so that is foreign to me
so I am I am taking the advice of people
that are younger than me I want to be
able to reach young people but I don't
want to be inauthentic and that's a
difficult thing for me to do because of
what really said you know I don't you
know techno nasty I'm not gonna dig on
people and I'll cancel anybody I'm not
gonna drag anybody and a lot of that
gets easy retweets but I can't do that
yeah I just think you know with the
mission of bloom 365 you can you want to
go into kids then the mission almost
demands it
oh absolutely no doubt about it demands
it and my personality demands it along
we're all just trying to live there's no
need for me to hurt you unnecessarily
it's like contradictory to my persona
yeah I mean yeah I know you think you're
don't being inauthentic I don't think I
don't think there's a bone in your body
that could you know stand up and be an
authentic in any environment no there is
and my husband's always laughing at me
since you stole I baby don't play poker
dude none of that stuff just go with
what you can go with what you got cuz
you don't have any options
ICU is kind of going into a giant
darkness and just spreading light I try
I really do I really really do and if I
can't do anything else I try to make
people laugh because that's just that's
the you know that's an opiate for the
soul that that that doesn't make anybody
else rich and it doesn't a dick yeah
yeah well I could definitely see a lot
of value whether whether its Instagram
lives like this or creating more content
on Instagram even just
your phone and making its its met
Instagram is meant to be authentic is
meant to be real it's meant to be it's
like I think it's just the perfect
platform designed for you Oh
message out there yeah and I just have
to be more confident in my ability to do
that and make sure that I understand
when to do it and how to do it and it's
just a matter of trial and error and I
ain't and I never tired of trying so I
love it well I'm excited to see where
all this goes for you and if I can be of
any help
technology-wise Instagram YouTube
whatever I want to see your message blow
up because I think it's really important
oh thank you so much and I enjoy you as
well I did I didn't know you till you
dropped in my my my tea I was like it
was cool it was it was a nice discovery
I'm I'm glad you reached out love it so
for people who are watching either
Instagram live or on YouTube we'll put
some links down below where do you want
them to go next what's the next step to
learn more about judge Lin and the
awesome projects you have going on well
i'm on instagram at real judge lynn and
twitter at real judge lynn my facebook
page my facebook page is real judge lynn
and i have a website judge lynn calm and
all youtube divorce court has a lot of
years of divorce court shows and you
know and then my books are available
from the one about my mother for
emotional support to one about marriage
to one about being a young woman and how
to how to manage that more effectively
so there are a lot of different avenues
you can you can reach me
well i got and guys bloom 365 org is the
the organization she set up the
non-profit to help end domestic violence
Jacqueline thank you so much the time
really appreciate you thank you so much
everyone it's all my much love will talk
sense alright take care bye if you want
to see the one on one I did with
Millionaire Matchmaker Patti
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you that why is it
so hard for entrepreneurs to find love
Shallow Hal has to leave the city for
love to come in